raise the hands how many people have
heard of Casper hey it's pretty good so
for the ones that haven't I'll give a
little explanation for those that have
this is probably how you know us as a
fairly well marketed company focused on
sleep we sell one single mattress we
sell one pillow we sell one set of
sheets I'm one of the cofounders there
were five of us background in product
design and development so I'll get into
in a sec I spent a lot of my time in
places much more like this than in the
fancier world of marketing so this is a
factory where we manufacture the covers
so it's a cut and sew facility in South
Carolina I've spent a lot of time here
and in other factories and today I want
to talk about eight things that I wish I
knew about building a supply chain so
you'll see in a sec that my background
is not in supply chain or operations I
don't know how many folks in the
audience think they'll start a company
or have started a company that involves
any physical object but building a solid
operations platform is critically
important so quick background I actually
studied civil engineering at Princeton
as an undergrad but I'm old enough that
I didn't have a digital camera so I
don't have photos from that time so I am
technical but I don't know how to
program so I'm maybe a halfway fit for
this for this presentation I went on a
study product design which is a mixture
of art mechanical engineering at
Stanford from there I moved to I do for
a decade did a lot of work in consumer
products a lot of work in medical
devices I left I do I started my own
company called common maid I spent a
couple years working in East Africa in
Southeast Asia in clean water and
sanitation working with World Bank and
Gates Foundation
oddly enough through that world came
across a cup
sorry this thing is finicky called water
wallah which was doing clean water
access in a slum in Mumbai it was
started by the guy in the back left Neel
Parikh who's one of the cofounders of
Casper he'll be featured bless him later
on in the presentation these other guys
were all friends in New York I only knew
Neil and four folks that were in the New
York who are familiar with the New York
startup scene a lot more of the consumer
focus single vertical branded companies
Warby Parker's bonobos come out of New
York not out of San Francisco and just
some out of LA so they're working
together doing different startups and
alright and notice a couple things one
amongst their peers and the people in
the incubator they were working within
that people weren't sleeping very much
statistics are kind of sad in 1942 we
were amidst the world war and people
slept more than they do now
when in the grand scheme of civilization
things are really peaceful there's also
this kind of stuff where people just I
mean the fact that you have your child
laying in bed reading an iPad is not
good for their sleep it's not good for
our sleep when we do the same thing and
so that's the general thing which Casper
was started to address we needed to
start somewhere by selling a product to
get into the sleep space and we started
with the foundational product and from a
consumer experience purchasing a
mattress is one of the worst things you
could imagine in terms of via the what
you get for the dollar the actual
shopping experience just way too much
choice your ill-informed to actually
know what you should be buying and if
you're getting getting a good product
for your money so we we boiled it all
down through a process of product
development iteration testing many
different types of mattresses on the
market developing our own and had the
idea that we would sell a single product
to the market we needed to we need to
convince somebody to fund us to start
this company because it's a very
expensive
and you'll see it caused us some
problems when you want to build
inventory when you're starting a company
it's hundreds of thousands of dollars to
millions of dollars just to build
initial inventory so as we were doing
our fundraising round we actually gave
away a lot of beds to venture
capitalists to try to get them to give
us money and they nobody would give us
money until they could sleep on our
product so in the picture here we
eventually led our been layer and layer
hippo layer Venture Partners let our
seed round and the right picture here is
the mattress that been layer had in his
apartment in the left is our Philip our
CEO of Luke or CMO delivering our
mattress to his house so we had to go in
when he wasn't there with his personal
assistant put in the new mattress take
out his old mattress and actually store
the old mattress until he was convinced
that he wanted to keep the new one and
he still sleeps on that prototype to
this day which is amazing and I'm pretty
sure it was he has a child now and it
was the first child ever conceived on a
Casper so this is the product we sell my
talks are not meant to be about product
design so I won't talk much about it but
just so you get a sense for those who
have an experience that aren't familiar
with it that mattress gets compressed
and rolled up and goes in a box it's
about 20 inches by 20 inches by 40
inches it's delivered via UPS in some
cities it's delivered via courier this
is a bike courier in New York delivering
it you get it to your house you unpack
it and then you instantly turn into a
stud
that's that's our sales message
so just to recap we started in April we
launched the public in April 2014 and it
was amazingly successful from day one we
did a million dollars in revenue in our
first month we've raised 70 million
dollars through a series B in 2015 we
did over a hundred million dollars in
revenue right about 150 people we have
our headquarters in New York we have a
design and supply chain office here in
San Francisco we have office in LA in
office in Berlin why were we successful
two things I think one three things one
I think the products great but I'm
biased I'm the one that designed it
we've had really creative marketing out
folks may have seen some of this
marketing on the on the bar this one's
my favorite
it was sleep like a narcissist because
you're dreaming of yourself dreaming of
yourself and then this which just blows
my mind there's an incredible amount of
social sharing of the Casper mattress
and the unboxing experience online
there's actually a video associated with
this which I won't show but we had a
problem we grew so fast that we couldn't
meet our sales demands and everyone says
it's a good problem to have but it's
incredibly stressful problem so to put
numbers to it we sold 139 beds on our
first day we had a hundred beds in stock
beds have a four to eight week lead time
to get made
we reached 35 days of backlog by October
so if you bought we promised in our
marketing message that you would get a
mattress the next day or the day after
some people had to wait five six weeks
to get a mattress we actually stayed in
backlog for 18 months and we've only
been around for 25 months and still the
day on some individual products we run
in the back
this is a huge problem it actually
slowed our growth we had to pull back on
our spend in order to allow our supply
chain to grow so I think we nailed
product we nailed marketing we nailed
brand we nailed the value proposition
but we totally missed on supply chain
and it goes back to what our original
team was there was five co-founders is a
large co-founding team our first
employees were in marketing and consumer
support we did not hire an Operations
person for a year so we went a year with
just me and Neil running our supply
chain and we didn't know what we were
doing so for those that have an ops or
supply chain background hopefully this
will be obvious but I'm just going to
run through eight stories and eight
quick learnings and some things that if
I were to do it again I would hopefully
do better and some are low-level points
some are high-level points first one
first story when we went to what ended
up being our main mattress supplier in
Georgia Neil and I flew down there we
stayed we shared a room and it days in
that was $30 a night we went to rent a
car online we could have rented a Chevy
Aveo for $40 or through sixth which is a
German rental car company we could have
rented a BMW for $40 clearly we rented
the BMW but then we pulled up into the
factory driving a really nice BMW which
is a terrible thing to do when you're
about to go into a negotiation about
what you want to pay for a product on
the same trip to the southeast we showed
up at the sewing factory which I showed
before and Neil's wearing that shirt
amongst people that are working their
butts off to get $12 an hour sewing
they thought it was funny but it was not
a great first impression
so my advice he deliberate in how you
dress how you arrived and what you
talked about we all have very great
indulgent luxurious lives the people you
work with on a supply chain probably
don't get $15 martinis they probably
don't talk about going bowling and
ping-pong indoors and indoor mini-golf
so when you're out of supply chain sight
or you have people in your supply chain
visiting you remember that we live a
very different life than most of these
people that would be supplying products
to us something's more serious everyone
will say they can do everything but it's
not true this is the this is the factory
where we pulled in with a BMW they make
from our opinion based on having visited
tons and tons of foam factories in the
US and overseas probably the best
quality raw material that we can find
they're really good at it
they also said that they could fabricate
mattresses it turns out they had never
really done it before but we were in a
rush to launch we were burning money and
it turned out that we went through a
huge amount of pain getting them up to
speed to learn how to do this step in
the process which is convert this raw
foam as it comes off of a production
line into a finished mattress it's a
really simple process you cut the pieces
to size and you glue them together and
you put a cover on it it shouldn't be
hard but it's very hard so if you're
going to work in a manufacturing
environment and hire a company right one
of the things we learned is that you
need to go step by step and make sure
that they they can actually and already
are actually doing everything that
you're asking them to do every supplier
or almost every supplier will tell you
they can do far more than they can
actually do and you need to figure out
what they're actually really good at
what their core competency is versus
like what yours are and if you need to
start bringing together multiple
suppliers
this supplier we also relied on them to
do e-commerce distribution so moving
those large mattresses to like a
third-party logistics firm which is
where most ecommerce products are
distributed from is very expensive
because they're so large you can only
fit if we were going to sell it shirts I
could fit thousands in a truck we can
only fit 200 beds in a truck so it's
very expensive to move them from the
factory to a distribution center just to
get shipped again so we had them do it
we estimate that they cost us around 30
to 40 thousand dollars a month in lost
product or miss ship product because we
were relying on them to do something
which they were not good at doing so
when you're on the if you're on the
factory floor there's a couple basic
things to look for standard operating
procedures force them to bring them out
and show them to you QA checks do they
have stations where they're monitoring
quality do they actually have dedicated
staff that's that's focused on
continuous improvement and quality if
you don't see people walking the floor
doing quality work it it means they're
they're not doing it at all in the
factory inventory management tools and
methods I think depending on the
industry you're in they'll have
different levels of sophistication of
how they track the raw materials and
finished goods we consign covers and a
couple and boxes and a couple products
that we purchase and give to our
suppliers they maintain some of them
maintain records through Excel
spreadsheets which is terrible because
we have no access to their Excel
spreadsheets they're not currently
updated so finding a supplier that has a
good ERP so an enterprise resource tool
is important from day one and a small
last thing just as we should be careful
what we dress like look at how they
dress look at how their floor workers
dress there's a in our experience a
really strong correlation between how
neat the people are and the quality of
work they produce so people if the
management gives everybody a polo shirt
or a t-shirt that matches and
look clean the odds are that the
management cares more about the quality
what they're going to produce join good
company so there's a step in the
manufacturing process for our product
where you apply a water-based glue to a
layer of foam and then you put another
layer of foam on top of it if you put
too little or too much it causes
problems and so there's a small step you
see going on here where they put a
sample piece like every 10 or 20 or 30
beds they put a small piece of foam
through and you weigh it before and you
weigh it after and you weigh you weigh
the difference and it tells you what the
density of glue or the concentration of
glue you're putting on the mattresses we
have worked with factories that have
done this and we worked with factories
that haven't and one of the things we
saw is that particularly for small
companies like us from the grand scheme
still small you guys small companies
find suppliers that are working for very
reputable established big companies in
our industry the very best is IKEA if we
find a company that's working for IKEA
we know that all of these things which
have caused us problems before are taken
care of so when you show up at a new
factory ask for their list of clients if
they're working for somebody that you
think is reputable so they get some
flack like IKEA Nike Nokia they're good
generally European companies or better
than American companies in terms of what
they force their supply chain to do so
get two lists of clients ask for testing
and inspection criteria so as a new
company you're going to have to create a
lot of processes in a lot of documents
if you can just borrow and adapt stuff
that up that large companies are already
created you'll be in a much better place
so they won't always share this with you
because I don't think like IKEA would
have been happy that our supplier shared
their test document with us but our
supplier did do that
same with product specifications writing
a solid product specification document
takes a huge amount of work and that
defines what you're actually going to
pay the supplier to make so you want to
make sure that it
of like utmost thoroughness in detail
getting a good template to start with is
hugely valuable if you want to be green
start green so the reason I bring this
up is we we as a company we found that
like selling an ecologic story is not
it's it's not very marketable
it doesn't make you sell more product
but it's important to us so what we what
we've done is on the quiet side gotten
certification around components so if we
look at the the raw materials that go in
any off gas then it comes off the
product the harvesting of any of those
raw materials we look for certification
around those individual things we ran
into a little bit of problem because
we'll be expanding into Europe and in
Europe particularly in the
german-speaking countries finished
product and ecological certification is
far more important to the consumer so we
were like okay we're good we have all
the certifications for this specifically
for a pillow so this I didn't reference
the picture but it's a weaving machine
weaving cotton shelves for pillows we
thought we would be good and so we
thought we could use the same supply
chain let's apply that product for
Germany the problem is the certification
required for Germany requires certified
finished product and certified fact the
factory that produces the finished
product has to be certified so we're in
the process of onboarding a totally new
factory and totally new supply chain
just to make a product for Germany
because we didn't think ahead enough to
get this this whole thing right for that
market so get finished good
certifications get factory level
certifications again follow industry
leaders if you follow a knight gear and
IKEA or Nokia into a factory the odds
are that there are eating to be
compliant with ecological or
environmental certifications and
restrictions and then we're going
through this right now some companies
have done it doing a B Corp assessment
or using it as a tool when you're
starting up is a four
they don't know it's a benefit
corporation pretty self-explanatory on
their website but it gives you a tool
around community conditions social
conditions environmental conditions it's
a really nice checklist to start with
suppliers are not your friends
this one's hard to remember I hate to
pick on Neal but this is Neal again I
think we were drunk in a basement bar in
Arkansas so my advice to you on this
with suppliers buy your own dinner don't
get drunk and if you're going to Asia
don't go to karaoke because it's not
really karaoke like it is back home and
for the guys in the audience the girls
there don't actually think you're
attractive so there's a couple things
here one I'm not going to jump ahead one
slide and go back read this book if you
haven't this explains all the reasons
why you should do none of these things
but unless you have spent 10 years in
sales or really gifted natural salesman
you are definitely outgunned by your
supplier salespeople they use all the
tools and their innate to them they love
closing the deal they use all the tools
as disposal to make you think that
they're your friend I got invited to Las
Vegas for free they're gonna put me up
in a suite in the Cosmopolitan one guy
invited me to his family's house on the
coast of Georgia to meet his wife
you wanted to go backpacking and it's I
don't mean to be negative but they've
all disappeared when we stop doing
business with them so they're not real
friendships they're friendships of
convenience for the supplier and it's
really hard when us when a supplier is
willing to spend 100 bucks or 200 bucks
on dinner for you to not take it my
feeling is you're better off buying them
dinner because they'll then become
indebted to you
vendor agreements again this is like a
really sticky legal document the
mattress shown on the left is our
mattress made in a fact
the mattress shown on the right is a
competitor mattress where we started we
were like in our opinion the first
branded ecommerce company to enter the
space by last count there's 41 companies
doing what Casper does here domestically
there's caught some in China some in
India some in Mexico some in Australia
they pop up all the time it's super
frustrating as we've work with our
suppliers to improve their processes to
see competitor small competitor
companies come in and gather the
knowledge that we've helped them build
and we've built ourselves so a vendor
agreement for people that don't know is
a legal contract between your company
and your supply chain that governs how
you guys work together and has all of
these things who owns IP meaning if
you're sitting talking with the supplier
about how to improve your product or how
to improve your manufacturing process
and a new idea comes up do you own it or
do they own it exclusivity are they
allowed to make the exact same thing for
a different company are they allowed to
make anything in your category of
products data sharing this one's
important for us we we closely monitor
the quality of the raw materials that go
into the product we want to know on a
day over day basis what the test data
they're getting back you but they're not
unless we're contractually obligated to
send it to us unless they are they're
less inclined to do it inventory
management this gets back to what I
mentioned before do they regularly
report this and we can you can tie all
this into a document that forces them
change-of-control three of our main
suppliers were purchased two weeks ago
by a single private equity firm in New
York City that's a change of control
allows us to renegotiate the contract
and there's some clauses in there which
allow us to change our relationship with
them chargebacks you're going to get
poor quality products sometimes every
every business does who pays for those
who pays for the consequences of those
warranty you definitely have to
negotiate and pricing transparency which
I'll get into on the next slide this is
very sad for
these two charts price to an index there
are two major commodities that make a
mattress you can see the pricing trends
of those two major commodities from when
we launched until now ones down 16
percent ones down 31 percent
how much of that money do you think
Casper saved 0 we didn't negotiate in
two things we didn't negotiate in
because we were at a rush we didn't
negotiate in volume discounts and we
didn't negotiate in any automated
pricing changes for our particular
product and it's going to be different
for different products it's very easy to
know what the raw material costs are
going in because they're commodities you
can purchase them you can track on the
market if we had been smarter in the
beginning we would have priced we would
have had price to the index we won't
capture all the savings but we should
have captured half of it and it's you
know I think the the first talk they
talked about gross margins and this
makes our business if we had captured
these it would make our business
two things one we'd be more profitable
or two we could pass the savings on to
our customers we didn't capture it so
the only people benefiting from this are
our suppliers which is now a private
equity firm and then last summing all
this up if I had if I had had or
somebody else on our team had had
experience in operations I wouldn't have
had to learn the previous seven things
on my own so my advice is if you're
gonna if you're gonna have a physical
product company you're going to
distribute something higher internal ops
expertise early it will pay for itself
and as an example we have a sea ship a
lot of stuff through ups we spend
millions of dollars a year because it's
not cheap to ship that box through ups
we just paid the bills because they come
in to accounting we had like a outsource
to firm I forget what's called propeller
doing our accounting they paid the bills
we went back recently as we've we've
recently hired a guy who came out of
Amazon and
will express in Black and Decker to run
our ops team he started digging back
through the bills there was a mattress I
got shipped to Fiji for like $1400 of
shipping there's no way we ship the
mattress to Fiji but it was buried in
our UPS bill we hired an analyst just to
look at this we anticipate based on
initial numbers that will save quite two
to three hundred thousand dollars just
by digging back through old bills and in
Reverse charging ups on those bills so
of the things other things to look at
the main things sourcing having a
dedicated person just out there looking
for multiple suppliers when you're in a
rush like we were you go to a smaller
number because you got to got to make a
decision to move fast
logistics keeping track of how your
product moves around warehousing you got
to know what's in inventory we're
planning you got to know particularly
things that are long lead time if you
got if you're going to be bringing
anything in from China or Taiwan you're
90 days on the water just to get it here
so you got to plan four or five six
months out you got to anticipate and
it's impossible when you're in a new
company to get it right but you could do
it much better than we did an analyst
just to watch your bills these all these
people you can think about as being free
because they will save you money or you
can do it the way we did it so I just
leave with one message if you make a
promise we make a promise to our
customers in terms of the quality of the
product the speed with which we want to
deliver it you actually have to deliver
on that promise as a startup you get a
lot of grace people will forgive you for
a while we think as the scale and the
time we've been in the market people are
no longer and I forgive Kasper for
messing things up and so you where you
have a little bit of a free time there
and then it runs out for you to have
actually deliver on the promise so I'll
leave you with that and then I guess I
think I'm going to take some Q&A
Thank You Jeff hey Jeff thank you for
your time
I just want to ask you mentioned you
should hire an internal ops person early
is that the title of that person inside
of another organization internal
operations um yeah the guy we hired is
VP of operations we have a director of
supply chain each of those each of these
things that I had here and again we're
larger so we can afford more people we
have people under each of these tasks
love will have probably by the end of
summer we'll have four people just doing
sourcing so you operations is the
general thing and then there's the sub
task underneath that got it alright
thank you yeah for sure I can you talk a
little bit about your product
development process and how you work
with your customers to decide what that
next product is going to be um yeah for
sure so that's actually like one of my
backgrounds in not in supply chain so I
might spent a long time at IDEO so if
you're familiar with that methodologies
what we practice so we spent a lot of
time talking to consumers so if we if we
know we want to make a pillow we're
going to go purchase all the things that
are on the market dissect them do sleeve
trials we're very fortunate to have a
exceedingly large group of dedicated
customers and this kind of virtual
entity we've created called Casper labs
I think there's like 15,000 members and
if we want to do survey work or product
testing work or at home interviews we oh
so we'll reach out to that group and see
if we can find participants but we
combine that user research product
analysis and then like a business
analysis of what do we think the holes
on the market are how how much value or
dollar volume can we get through a
product category and then we just follow
the paths to through that process to
figure out what we want to make thank
you Jeff
thank you guys all right